algún perfeccionista en esta sala me
ayudan levantando la mano si alguien
aquí se considera perfeccionista los que
la tienen así como la mitad bien bien
levantada
bueno hace algunos años fui a una
entrevista de trabajo a una de estas
grandes empresas con interminables
pasillos y cuando me acerqué a mi
reclutador me pidió que le mencionara
tres cualidades y tres defectos y yo
insegura decidida y confiada dije como
una de mis cualidades soy perfeccionista
igual y acto seguido ya le pude haber
dicho al lado de soy perfeccionista soy
infeliz vivo insatisfecha y siento que
no hago nada bien porque me infecte con
esta plaga que me hace creer a mí y a
todos los que la padecemos o estamos
contaminados por ella que es una buena
idea perseguir una vida llena de
expectativas imposibles de alcanzar
porque con el perfeccionismo no importa
lo que seamos hagamos o tengamos al
parecer siempre se puede hacer mejor y
mejor y mejor y mejor y es como un ciclo
que no tiene fin desde hace dos años doy
un taller al rededor de la repubblica
que se llama transforma tus sueños en
plan de vida y me encanta porque la
gente se acerca a mí a contarme sus
sueños sus planes y sus proyectos y lo
tienen clarísimo es como si vieran una
película frente a ellos y me cuentan con
lujo de detalle que cómo cuándo dónde
por qué con quién pero acto seguido de
todas estas cosas que podrían ser me
cuentan las razones por las que no es
y se las pueden listar hoy porque ya me
la sé de memoria no importa la ciudad o
la edad de estas personas siempre es
algo como empecé muy chico o es muy
tarde no estoy preparado no estudie para
esto no tengo los contactos no tengo el
financiamiento necesito un inversionista
que crea en mi idea e invierta en ella
el millón de pesos o el cazatalentos que
está sentado en su oficina desde hace 22
años esperando tu dulce voz
el punto es que siempre está a la espera
de algo y los entiendo perfecto porque
alguna vez yo estuve ahí mismo
estacionada en todas las razones y los
cuentos que me contaba a mí misma de por
qué no era una buena idea ir por eso que
tanto quería y al igual que ellos yo lo
tenía súper claro sabía que quería
comunicar ideas contar historias usar mi
voz tener un micrófono en la mano sabía
en qué canal de televisión quería
trabajar es más lo tenía tan claro que
sabía que algún día iba a dar un texto
pero del otro lado de la balanza tenía
todas las razones por las cuales era una
mejor idea no intentarlo y algo así era
lo que pasaba por mi cabeza esta es muy
grande te decidiste muy tarde esto ya es
un sueño frustrado ojo tenía 21 años
no tienes ninguna experiencia nunca has
hecho nada en este medio quien te hizo
creer que eras buena no sabes pararte
frente a la televisión cómo vas a
improvisar conducir una alfombra en vivo
y del inglés al español leer un prompter
tener un apuntador no tienes ni idea no
tienes el cuerpo perfil o closet que
tienen las mujeres que se dedican a lo
mismo que tú
no conoces a nadie en el medio mueves
muchísimo las manos vas a distraer a
todo el mundo
es más mi perfeccionista interno iba tan
profundo que yo ya estaba pensando que
iba a ser el día que estuviera
entrevistando a matthew mcconaughey a
chris hemsworth oa blake lively y
tuviera que saludarlos de mano y mis
manos estuvieron empapadas de sudor
porque mis manos viven empapadas de
sudor al grado que agradezco no tener a
nadie muy cerquita porque siento que
salpicó pero lo que les quiero decir
es que ninguno de estos cuentos que me
contaba a mí misma eran mentira en
realidad yo no tenía ninguna experiencia
en este medio lo cual me dio toda la
frescura para tener algo nuevo que
ofrecer
y si en efecto no estudié comunicación
ni actuación y tenía mucha idea de nada
y no tenía un quinto porque nadie
financió mis sueños
así que comía dos veces al día pan
tostado sin untable porque no me
alcanzaba mientras dormía en el sillón
de diferentes amigos pero con eso me
aseguré que estuviera en este lugar por
las razones correctas y no tenía el
cuerpo perfil o closet de ninguna de las
mujeres pero eso me obligó a tener algo
más que ofrecer cuando estuviera parada
frente a la cámara y si mis manos nunca
dejaron de moverse pero eso se convirtió
en mi distintivo y ni modo el día que
tuve a chris hemsworth a matthew
mcconaughey a blake lively sentados en
frente de mí tuve que saludarlos de beso
porque mis manos estaban muy sudas
pero a lo que voy es que llega un día en
que esta historia refrita que te cuentas
a ti mismo de por qué no vas por las
cosas caduca
porque el hambre no cesa
porque cuánto tiempo puede durar un
autoengaño o cuántas vidas estás
dispuesto a esperar antes de encontrar
el valor de ir por eso que tanto quieres
pero sobre todo la pregunta que más
ruido me hacía a mí era que me voy a
contar a mí misma cuando tenga 80 años
de porque no fui por eso que tanto
quería o porque no al menos lo intente
ninguna de estas razones tuvieron el
peso suficiente para seguir con el
autoengaño lo único que sí vivía dentro
de mí era el hubiera que hubiera pasado
y les voy a decir una cosa con él
hubiera él hubiera existe e insiste él
hubiera tiene pies cabeza respira
retumba y retumba bien fuerte aquí
adentro porque lo hubiera es todas las
veces que no nos atrevemos a ir por algo
ese día empaque mis cosas mis miedos y
mis sueños en una misma maleta y empecé
el viaje que me trajo hoy aquí y que
espero que no termine nunca pero desde
entonces creo que todas estas razones
que nos contamos a nosotros mismos
son pequeños adormecedores para cuando
esa personita soñadora que vive aquí
adentro y que vive adentro de todos
ustedes porque todos tenemos la
capacidad de soñar y eso es algo que
nadie nos va a poder arrebatar nunca
pero cuando esa personita soñadora y
adentro toque la puerta y diga
porque no estamos yendo por esto que
tantas ganas tenemos de hacer
porque no le estamos diciendo a esta
persona como en realidad nos sentimos
entonces tú te vuelvas a contar esta
historia
y mientras nosotros estamos esperando el
momento perfecto para decirlo la
oportunidad perfecta para empezar el
hombre o la mujer perfecta para
complementarnos lo que sea que estemos
esperando que sea perfecto lo único que
pasa mientras nosotros esperamos es la
vida nos estamos perdiendo la capacidad
de vivir la vida como es siempre a
espera de algo
siempre a espera de algo
y en la cultura japonesa lo entienden
muy bien hay un arte tradicional que se
llama el kit sung y cuando una pieza de
cerámica se rompe ellos la reparan con
un adhesivo y después la rocían con oro
convirtiendo a esta pieza en una mucho
más fuerte y valiosa que todas las demás
porque ellos entienden que las grietas y
las imperfecciones cuentan historias así
somos nosotros los humanos estamos
llenos de grietas de cicatrices y de
imperfecciones
pero todas esas cuentan nuestra historia
y es justo ahí donde se esconden
nuestras mejores partes
justo en esos lugares porque no usarlas
a nuestro favor y porque seguimos
alcanzando este ideal de perfección que
no existe
la perfección no es como yo lo creía en
esa entrevista de trabajo hace muchos
años una cualidad la perfección es una
carga enorme una losa que pesa kilos y
kilos en la espalda
una de mis autoras favoritas reiner
braun lo pone muy bien en palabras y
ella explica que la caminata de 15
minutos que salimos a dar es mejor que
la carrera de 10 km que no vamos a
correr
y la columna que publicaste con una
falta de ortografía es mejor que la
columna que nunca te atreviste a
publicar
el pastel que cocinas está inspirado en
esa foto divina de pinter east que no sé
si soy la única que los pasteles de
pinter se me quedan como malteadas no sé
por qué pero eso malteada es mejor que
el pastel que nunca te vas a animar a
cocinar
porque la vida no es un mapa y para
fortuna mía tampoco es un instructivo de
interés
pero las reglas van cambiando todo el
tiempo y pensar que no estamos listos
para algo es una buena manera de nunca
hacer nada
porque la perfección congela paraliza
nos hace creer que somos insuficientes y
no nos deja empezar a hacer nada
pero lo que hoy les vengo a contar es
que hay una buena noticia hay un
antídoto y hay una cura para esta
perfección que se combate una decisión
valiente a la vez y un día a la vez
y el antídoto aunque suene fácil y
sencillo es empezar
empezar hoy desde donde estás con las
posibilidades que tienes y con lo que
tienes no empezar mañana no empezar el
lunes no empezar en enero no empezar
cuando todas las cosas sean como tú las
imaginas perfectamente en tu cabeza
y si saltar al vacío a la tierra es
aterrador porque no tenemos certeza de
nada
pero solamente saltando al vacío es que
se empieza a romper en cachitos el
hubiera y los fantasmas que nos
atormentan y todas esas cosas que no nos
dejan avanzar porque solamente saltando
al vacío podemos medir el tamaño y la
fuerza de nuestras alas
pero para eso tenemos que empezar ya
[Aplausos]